[Music]
how are you Russell
well firstly I love being here on your
program I love you I love those men over
there I love all of those people somehow
[Applause]
well you've come to the right place and
first question I know you are not from
this country originally did you land I
came here from on an armed burg I heard
yes sources silvery lake yes yes there
to be an airplane in the Atlantic Ocean
we agree to disagree : the facts are not
clear yeah semantics yes I'm curious did
you follow our election that's a big
deal here did you follow it no I don't
want to hurt anyone's feelings because I
know that everyone was trying their
hardest there was the man that has many
children there is the man is already the
president I didn't mind because I think
everyone's just trying their best I'm
happy the one that won won but I don't
know which one that was because last
night the cat had an incident your cat
had an incident so you didn't really
follow what was going on with the
election some bachelor parties Conan
okay I apologize did you did you root
for one candidate over another who did
was you did you care really at all was
the Queen on the ballot no the Queen was
not on the ballot and I must focus on
the cat
do you think we should have a queen here
do you prefer a monarchy to our
democracy is that what you're saying
yeah because she's ever so kind you
couldn't have a queen if you wanted and
you could also have a president also it
doesn't matter you're singing the United
States you think we can have a president
and then we could also have a queen I
think we could incorporate animals into
government I think we could have monkeys
and government little bullish children
honey boo boo all in charge just happens
little clockwork mice so you weren't
following this at all you really weren't
you telescope I can see Jupiter there
are moons going round it there is an
infinite fragile galaxy out there a
world of wonder it takes like one second
to seven times go round the cut the
planet earth what we live on the Hubble
Space Telescope can see twenty six point
five billion light years away Conan what
happens on this tiny rock is almost
irrelevant and no one is helping my cat
[Applause]
those girls with different color hair
for everyone else yeah look at that
they really stand out those two girls
right there give them a hand there just
sat there like that and why is no one
troubling therefore low-beam joobs the
hell are you talking about that is the
pathway to the ovum's the ovaries the
Babymakers sure we could make other
asses inside of those Mandi what are you
talking about children yes you're so
focused magic and Wonder yeah I am do
you mind if I briefly just go and
impregnate one or both of them they need
to be consenting oh they're fine with it
they're they think they're clapping at
the concept of pregnancy